nordatlantikrats bekam
auch der alfa bulgariens der
tschechiens polens
und tschechiens gesprochen dringende
konsultationen abzuhalten unter artikel
4 des washingtoner vertrags
es ist ein schwerer moment für europa
und profitierte nicht begründete angriff
russlands
bedeutet dass viele leben in gefahr sind
die nichts dafür können es gibt
luftangriffe es gibt angriffe auf der
erde in alle möglichen richtungen es
geht um militärische infrastruktur und
größere urbane zentren
dies ist ein bewusster kalt politiker
lang geplanter eine lang geplante
invasion
trotz der litanei den zügen der
verleugnungen und der desinformation
sind die intentionen das kam es jetzt
klar auf der hand für die welt die
führungskräfte in russland tragen volle
verantwortung für diese hoch ist losen
handlungen und die verlorenen leben die
bündnispartner der nato verdammen diese
invasion der ukraine durch die russland
mit den härtesten
ist eine ganz klare verletzung des
völkerrechts eklatant und es geht gegen
ein souveränes friedvolles land
eine
ernsthafte bedrohung der
euroatlantischen sicherheit
wir rufen russland dazu auf sofort die
militärischen aktionen zu beenden
streitkräfte aus der ukraine zurück zu
ziehen und zur diplomatie zurückzukehren
wir unterstützen die souveränität und
territoriale integrität der ukraine voll
und ganz und ihr recht auf
selbstverteidigung
russland verwendet
macht um die geschichte umzuschreiben
und spricht der ukraine das recht auf
freiheit und unabhängigkeit
die hauptaufgabe der nato ist es alle
bündnispartner zu schützen und zu
verteidigen
es darf keinen raum für eine miss
kalkulieren oder missverständnisse geben
ein angriff auf einen bündnispartner
gilt als ein angriff auf alle
das ist unsere kollektive
sicherheitsgarantie
der nordatlantikrat hat heute
beschlossen
auf antrag von general tod wollte die
verteidigung den verteidigungsfall
einzuberufen dies ist ein wichtiger
schritt um alle nationen dieser krise zu
schützen es wird es uns möglich machen
kapazitäten und streitkräfte einzusetzen
auch die nato angriffs truppe dort wo
sie benötigt wird in reaktion auf die
massiven militärischen aufbau russlands
strengten stärken wir unsere kollektive
sicherheit auf land in der see und in
der luft in den letzten wochen haben
bündnispartner aus nordamerika und
europa tausende oder mehr truppen in den
ostteil der allianz verlegt und noch
mehr in stand by gehalten im
bereitschafts haben über 100 jets in
hohe einsatzbereitschaft zum schutz
unseres luftraums und mehr als 120
schiffe
vom hohen norden bis zum mittelmeerraum
all dies zeigt dass artikel 5
tatsächlich
durchgesetzt wird unsere kollektive
sicherheit wir werden alles weiterhin
tun was nötig ist um uns vor aggression
zu schützen
ich habe einen virtuellen
gipfel der nato
führungskräfte für morgen einberufen um
zu sehen wie es weitergehen soll
russland sieht sich jetzt schweren
konsequenzen und kosten gegenüber
gegenüber der gesamten internationalen
gemeinschaft das ziel
ist es seine einflusssphäre neu zu
definieren und die globalen regeln die
uns seit jahrzehnten sicher gehalten
haben aufzubrechen und unsere werte zu
untergraben
das ist das nur für unsere sicherheit
der neuen normalzustand
frieden kann nicht als
selbstverständlich erachtet werden
freiheit und demokratie werden durch
autokratische regimes in frage gestellt
und es gibt hier strategischen
wettbewerb der immer stärker wird wir
müssen darauf reagieren
mit stärkerer entschlossenheit und
stärkerer noch stärkere einigkeit
nordamerika und europa gemeinsam in der
nato
wir sind ein bündnis von 30 demokratien
die wie einst behandeln wir werden
unsere menschen und unsere werte
schützen
die demokratie wird immer vorrang haben
über autokratie die freiheit wird immer
vorrang haben über unterdrückung
ich bin jetzt bereit fragen hingegen
zunehmend
interfax ukraine wird
in den fond
geben dem sommer interfax ukraine
generalsekretär wir wissen alle dass die
nato nicht kämpfen wird für die ukraine
glauben sie aber nicht dass es an der
zeit ist dass die nato
eine anti putin koalition aufzubauen
danke
nato steht solidarisch
für die ukraine und die
nato-bündnispartner
erleben russland erhebliche kosten auf
für diese hoch lose invasion der ukraine
die bündnispartner der nato in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der eu und allen
partnern weltweit erlegen ernsthafte
wirtschaftssanktionen auf
russland um zu demonstrieren
dass unseren worten taten folgen und
dass es ein hoher preis sein wird in
russland zu zahlen hat die nato partner
haben auch schon lange unterstützung
praktisch unterstützung geleistet
militärische unterstützung für die
ukraine und haben eine sehr viel besser
ausgerüstet und ausgebildet die
streitkräfte in der ukraine das ist noch
dass der fall im vergleich zu 2014 sie
besser aufgestellt mit unserer hilfe und
ich
möchte auch die professionalität und den
wagemut der ukrainischen männer und
frauen offiziell anerkennen die sich
hier gegen die russische invasion
erheben wir stehen weiterhin gemeinsam
zusammen verurteilen
wollen in versionen der ukraine durch
russland die bündnispartner stehen auch
darin zusammen dass die botschaft
aussenden dass wir niemals akzeptieren
werden einen eine brutale verletzung des
völkerrechts wie wir es derzeit erleben
sowie russland jetzt die ukraine
einnimmt
haben sie informationen die besagen dass
nato bündnispartner direkt von russland
bedroht sind im moment und würde nato
noch einmal überlegen ob sie nicht doch
militärisch eingreifen in der ukraine
das stark vermögens in der geschichte
und wir werden das auf jeden fall
verteidigen wir werden jeden alliierten
jeden bündnispartner schützen gegen
jeglichen angriff auf seinem territorium
deshalb haben wir unsere präsenz im
östlichen teil der allianz mit tausenden
mehr truppen schiffen und flugzeugen den
letzten wochen verstärkt um eine ganz
klare botschaft auszusetzen dass ein
angriff auf einen bündnispartner eine
reaktion aller bündnispartner
hervorrufen wird das tun wir nicht um
konflikte herauszufordern sondern um sie
zu vermeiden
defensiv ist es genau bemessen aber ist
es auch notwendig verhältnismäßig aber
notwendig denn wir haben gesehen wie
russland sich der ukraine gegenüber
aggressiv verhalten hat daher müssen die
bündnispartner auch sicherstellen dass
es keinen raum gibt zu
missverständnissen russland könnte
niemals so etwas gegen einen nato
bündnispartner tun
generalsekretär sie haben in statement
gesagt dass wir zusätzliche
verteidigungs land und luft kräfte
einsetzen und die bereitschaft der
streitkräfte erhöhen
werden heute noch mehr streitkräfte
entsandten nach dieser in version oder
meinen sie das was bereits geschehen ist
bei der verstärkung denn
jetzt wird es den möglichkeiten geben
zusammen zu kommen ohne noch einmal
zurückzukommen zum sicherheitsrat zur
genehmigung und werden dass ich noch
einmal hinsetzen mit präsident putin
oder anderen vertretern der russischen
regierung nachher nach dieser geschichte
oder wir erhalten sie die möglichkeit
offen weitere gespräche zu führen
in version ist keine überraschung wir
haben seit monaten davor gewarnt und
leider
ist das was heute morgen in der nacht
geschehen ist etwas worauf sich die
bündnispartner und ihre geheimdienste
schon lange vorbereitet hatten das wurde
schon lange vorher gesagt wir haben
versucht es zu vermeiden denn russland
zu diplomatischen schritten ermuntert
haben wir haben auch gewarnt vor
wirtschaftlichen kosten und sanktionen
falls sie weiter die invasion in die
ukraine betreiben aber was wir jetzt in
den letzten
stunden erlebt haben bedeutet dass
russland trotz unserer diplomatischen
bemühungen und unsere botschaften
unserer planung für wirtschaft
funktionen dennoch beschlossen hat die
in die ukraine einzumarschieren
da wir ja
schon lange davor gewarnt haben haben
wir auch die entsprechenden sinnvollen
maßnahmen ergriffen um uns vorzubereiten
und aus diesem grund haben wir in den
letzten monaten und wochen die präsenz
erheblich erhöht von nato-truppen im
östlichen teil des bündnisses wir haben
bodentruppen aber auch luft und marine
und wir werden in den nächsten tagen das
noch weiter erhöhen wir sind schon dabei
präsenz im östlichen teil der allianz zu
verstärken wir haben jetzt die
nato-verteidigungsminister
wird mit denen unsere militärischen
anführer truppen bewegen können und
einsetzen wo notwendig und das ist
natürlich dann auch teile der nato
reaktions drucke sein der eingreiftruppe
und wir sind bereit aber was wir tun ist
auf jeden fall verhältnismäßig es ist
auf abwehr ausgerichtet wir wollen
konflikte vermeiden und ein angriff auf
irgendein bündnispartner der nato
wir haben schon seit wochen hunderten
russland
zu erreichen und was wir erlebt haben
ist dass die russische botschaft gewesen
ist dass sie
diese gespräche offensichtlich nie ernst
genommen haben denn während wir versucht
haben zu einer politischen lösung zu
kommen haben sie diese in version
geplant und während wir versucht haben
eine politische lösung zu finden haben
sie tag für tag woche für woche ihre
militärische präsenz an den grenzen der
ukraine weiter verstärkt und jetzt haben
sie die invasion losgetreten das heißt
russland hat eine politischen lösung die
tür verschlossen wir bedauern das aber
leider ist das die realität
das hat eben erhebliche ernsthafte
folgen für die menschen in der ukraine
aber auch auf die sicherheit unter aller
und das ist der grund weshalb wir unsere
präsenz im ostteil des bündnisses
verstärken
ich habe zwei fragen erst einmal musste
ich gerne ihre reaktion auf das was herr
präsident putin heute morgen sagte als
er die militärischen operationen
ankündigte er sagte da das ein jegliches
land das deutsche eingreift konsequenzen
erleben würde die stärker werden als sie
in der geschichte gesehen und ich lege
das aus als ein notlager drohen mit
einem atomangriff ich wüsste gerne wie
sie das sehen er hat nicht gesagt genau
was eingreifen heißt zweitens kann der
nato russland
diese akte erhalten bleiben unter den
gegebenen umständen
droht
putin und die aggressiven handlungen
russland sind natürlich der grund
weshalb wir sagen dass wir jetzt eine
neue situation für unsere sicherheit
haben und wir müssen unsere
bündnispartner genau
konsultieren das werden wir morgen tun
auf dem virtuellen und zu sehen was das
langfristig bedeutet für unsere
beziehung mit russland wie können wir
weiterhin unsere bündnispartner
verteidigung und schützen in dieser
neuen sicherheits realität und wie
können wir sicherstellen dass wir die
werte an die wir glauben freiheit und
demokratie aufrechterhalten angesichts
der aggressiveren des aggressiven
autoritären regimes in moskau das dazu
bereit ist ganz offen gegen unsere werte
vorzugehen und
gewalt einzusetzen um andere nationen zu
besetzen das wird also langfristige
auswirkungen haben auf unsere sicherheit
darauf wie wir reagieren wie die nato
reagiert und wie unsere beziehung mit
russland sich weiterentwickeln kann wir
haben heute noch nicht alle antworten
aber es wird eine neue realität geben es
wird ein neues europa sein
nach der invasion die wir heute erlebt
haben
daher begrüße ich die tatsache dass wir
uns so eng miteinander abstimmen so eng
zusammenarbeiten in der nato
wir haben gemeinsam gegen die russische
aggression pläne gewandt wir haben
gemeinsam und an russland gewarnt beim
versuch diesen angriff zu vermeiden und
jetzt müssen wir eben auch gemeinsam
diesen angriff abwehren und genau das
tun wir auch wahr dass jetzt die erste
rede
ja also das teil der neuen realität die
wir uns jetzt anschauen müssen es wird
eine andere realität sein aber heute ist
noch nicht der tag schlussfolgerungen zu
ziehen wir werden das aber morgen unter
den regierungschefs besprechen
generalsekretär die ukraine hat heute
die türkei dazu aufgerufen den bosporus
zu schließen und die dardanellen für
russische schiffe ist das eine aktion
die heute morgen bei der sitzung
besprochen wurde und gibt es ähnliche
handlungen anreiz die vielleicht heute
schon besprochen wurden
das wurde in der sitzung leute nicht
besprochen die türkei ist natürlich ein
nato bündnispartner die türkei hat eine
ganz besondere rolle angesichts des
bosporus aber das war nicht thema heute
morgen in der sitzung worüber wir
gesprochen haben heute morgen mal die
notwendigkeit dass wir jetzt die
verteidigungs klaus aktivieren müssen
wir müssen diese pläne aktivieren die
ist sehr möglich machen streitkräfte
schneller dorthin zu bewegen wo sie
benötigt werden und es wird auch eine
erklärung geben wir ganz klar eine
verurteilung der russischen invasion der
ukraine aussprechen
außerdem haben wir angekündigt dass wir
einen nato gipfel morgen abhalten lehre
nutzer virtuell
können sie uns etwas mehr sagen zur
aktivierung des verteidigungs plan was
genau gezählt wann wurde dies zum
letzten mal gemacht danke
diese pläne sind die wir über die jahre
entwickelt haben um sicherzustellen dass
es überhaupt pläne gibt in reaktion auf
krisen wie die krise der wir uns heute
gegenüber
es sind verteidigungspläne sie sind sehr
vorsichtig
umsichtig und sie decken die östlichen
allianz bis zum mittelmeer ab
und damit haben unsere
kommandeure mehr befehlsgewalt
innerhalb
bestimmter leitlinien und rahmen sie
können dann streitkräfte dort einsetzen
wo sie für richtig halten und genau
darauf haben wir uns heute geeinigt das
sind also verteidigungspläne defensive
art wir wollen sicherstellen dass für
streitkräfte haben die bereit sind an
der richtigen stelle
europaweit
wurden diese pläne gift zu frohe
aktiviert ich weiß nicht ob es richtig
wäre diese fragen zu beantworten für
mich denn ich weiß nicht ob es
öffentlich gemacht wurde in der
vergangenheit ich sage nur heute wurden
sie aktiviert diese pläne
diese
nato-angriff gruppe ist sie jetzt in der
ukraine kommen nein es gibt es keine
nato kampftruppen überhaupt keine nato
truppen innerhalb der ukraine wir haben
klargestellt dass wir keine pläne haben
und keine intentionen haben nato truppen
in die ukraine zu entsenden
was wir klar gestellt haben ist dass wir
jetzt die truppen erhöht haben die
präsenz der nato dritten im östlichen
teil des nato bündnisses auf nato
territorium
die ukraine ist ein wertvoller partner
wir haben sie schon seit vielen vielen
jahren unterstützt wir haben ihnen
geholfen eine sehr steife streitmacht
aufzubauen
militärisch wir haben sie ausgebildet
werden sie ausgerüstet und in vielerlei
hinsicht die streitkräfte der ukraine
unterstützte wir haben auch
den nato bündnispartner geholfen aber
wir haben keine nato truppen innerhalb
der ukraine und wir haben auch keine
pläne nato truppen in die ukraine zu
entsenden aber wir sind bereit alle nato
bündnispartner zu schützen wir
unterstützen also die ukraine und wir
geben absolute sicherheitsgarantien für
nato bündnispartner und dieses
engagement demonstrieren wir mit der
erhöhten präsenz diesen teil des
bündnisses
es gibt auch noch online fragen
stellen die new york times
kurze fragen erstens
haben sie immer noch sie als nato
kontakte militärischer kontakte mit
russischen zum derzeit und
viele
nato-länder werden wir weiterhin waffen
zu liefern wollen an die ukraine
denken sie das könnte ein erhöhtes
risiko sein dass die nato und russland
in konflikt geraten und wo sehen sie
noch zu einem konflikt zwischen russland
und nato
ländern der vielleicht noch etwas
schlimmeres ausarten könnte
wir haben die präsenz im östlichen teil
des
verstärkt wir haben die nato
verteidigungspläne jetzt aktiviert damit
es eben keinen überschwappen auf nato
territorium gibt denn solange russland
weiß dass ein angriff auf einen nato
bündnispartner bedeutet dass die gesamte
das gesamte buchungs reagiert wie so
lange werden sie nicht angreifen denn
die sind das stärkste bündnis in der
geschichte und so lange wir
zusammenstehen und klarmachen
dass wir
durch unsere
gemeinschaftliche sicherheits engagement
tatsächlich verpflichtet sind ist das
die beste möglichkeit einen angriff zu
vermeiden und eine tragödie wie bisher
in der ukraine gesehen haben sollte aber
auf keinen
nato-bündnis land übergehen können
nato-gipfels partner haben der ukraine
in vieler hinsicht in den letzten jahren
unterstützung gegeben vor allem seit
2014 mit cyber
verteidigung auch verschiedene fonds
aktivitäten und darüber hinaus also
kapazitäten aufbau
die stärken
der marine kräfte und andere teile der
streitkräfte aber
nato bündnispartner haben auch wir uns
einige haben auch verteidigungs waffen
und ausrüstung geliefert haben auch
ausbildung geboten und da gab es viele
gleich unterstützung ist dass es werden
dann aber die
nato-bündnispartner jeder für sich
entscheiden es ist sehr wichtig dass es
kontakte gibt zwischen unsere
militärischen führungskräften und
russland wir sind weiterhin in kontakt
um sicherzustellen dass wirklich alles
getan wird damit der konflikte abgebaut
werden kann kommt jetzt nach helsinki
die hessinnen
und hessen damit
was ist ihre botschaft an findet in
schweden in dieser situation zumindest
in finnland wird eine mögliche nato
mitgliedschaft diskutiert aber ist das
realistisch in zeiten dieser krise dank
finnland und schweden sind sehr enger
partner und ich habe da eine ganz klare
botschaft an normen sowohl von finnland
als auch von schweden dass sie sagen
obwohl sie im moment einen beitritt
beantragen dass sie doch glauben dass
die nato kann allerlei
abkommen mit russland unterzeichnen
sollte also keine rechtlich
verpflichtende
abkommen oder vereinbarung womit die
nato erweiterung für die zukunft beendet
wird also schweben und finden für sie
ist es eine frage der selbstbestimmung
des souveränen rechts den eigenen weg
auszugehen und dann potenziell in der
zukunft könnte man auch sich auf eine
nato mitgliedschaft bewerben
für mich ist also ganz trafen und
schweden haben das untermauert wie
wichtig es ist dass nato bündnispartner
keine kompromisse eingehen
einschließlich des rechts einer
jeglichen nationen sein eigenes
schicksal zu wählen also ob man der nato
angehören will oder nicht
beachtet dieser ley entscheidungen
unabhängig davon ob es ein ja oder ein
nein ist zum arbeitet
die enge partnerschaft mit finnland und
schweden ist für uns für natur sehr sehr
wichtig auch befinden und beschrieben
und gemeinsam auch mit dem
nordatlantikrat sehen wir schon wie enge
zusammenarbeiten wie unsere
möglichkeiten gemeinsam zu operieren
verbessern interoperabilität ist das
stichwort und auch konsultation
militärischer art und insofern habe ich
schweden und finnland eingeladen
auf den virtuellen gipfel morgen genauso
gut sind und bei dem morgigen
nato-gipfel werden schweden und finnland
anwesend sein
und die beiden eu präsidenten
eine sehr starke klandt atlantische nato
einigkeit und auch die eng mit den
engsten partnern zu demonstrieren in
allen städten das polnische radio
ich hätte noch eine anschließende frage
wir haben bereits tausende von truppen
wir haben truppen aus dem vereinigten
königreich und
länder im östlichen teil des bündnisses
mehr schiffe in der ostsee mehr luftraum
schutz auf mehr als flugzeuge das
geschieht jetzt schon das wort mehr
kräfte leben in den nächsten tagen und
wochen im östlichen teil des bündnis ist
das könnte auch sein dass die nato eine
gruppe elemente davon zum einsatz kommen
aber es geht nicht darum um welche
elemente oder welche genauen kräfte dort
eingesetzt werden sondern es geht vor
allem für polen die andere
bündnispartner darum dass mehr nato
präsenz im osten gibt und es wird noch
mehr truppen geben in den nächsten tagen
und wochen